Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Les hommes dominent les femmes.
Ce n'est pas un scoop.
Encore aujourd’hui,
elles gagnent en moyenne
19 % de moins que les hommes.
Elles assument 75 % des tâches ménagères
et dans les médias français,
seulement 20 % des experts
interrogés sont des expertes.
Je veux dire qu’ils prennent presque
toute la place dans la sphère publique.
Ils accèdent aux postes à responsabilités,
donc les mieux payés.
Ils font les lois
et organisent la société.
Imaginez maintenant qu’en plus de cela,
ils voient couler du sang
de leurs organes génitaux
tous les mois.
Et oui, dans cette fiction,
les hommes ont leurs règles.
Puisqu’ils possèdent
le pouvoir de donner la vie,
ils sont considérés
comme de véritables héros.
D’ailleurs, plus un homme
a des règles abondantes,
plus il est considéré
comme solide et viril.
Les hommes étant omniprésents
dans la sphère politique,
les menstruations sont au cœur
des intérêts de toute l’humanité.
On en parle tous les jours,
librement, sans honte.
En médecine, dans cette fiction toujours,
les maladies liées aux règles
sont très bien connues.
L'exemple de l'endométriose est flagrant.
Cette maladie, qui cause d’intenses
douleurs aux hommes, voire l’infertilité,
a été la pierre angulaire
de la construction
de l’Organisation mondiale de la santé.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Du coup, vous vous souvenez
de la phrase du président américain
lors de son discours inaugural
de l’OMS en 48
« Au 21e siècle, plus aucun homme
ne souffrira d’endométriose. »
Quel homme !
Et de fait, dès la sortie de la guerre,
les menstruations ont été le dossier phare
des ministères de la Santé
partout dans le monde.
Le grand général de Gaulle
lui-même avait créé
un sous-secrétariat aux menstruations.
(Rires)
Si, si.
Et aujourd’hui, certaines
politiciennes se disent « lassées »,
veulent faire valoir
« d’autres priorités »,
comme en Nouvelle-Zélande, par exemple,
avec son gouvernement misandre qui,
au nom de l’écologie
a proposé une augmentation des taxes de 3%
sur les protections hygiéniques
masculines jetables.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Ça aurait été le premier pays du monde
à ne plus reconnaître les tampons,
les serviettes à usage unique
comme des produits de première
nécessité et donc, non taxés.
Mais quelle honte !
D’ailleurs, comme on dit :
« Femmes au pouvoir, progrès au placard. »
Mais c’est vrai, la précarité
menstruelle a toujours été
une priorité en matière
d’aide au développement.
Ça fait partie du b.a.-ba de l’hygiène.
On l’apprend à l’école sans doute
depuis Charlemagne.
(Rires)
Et de manière générale, les menstruations,
c’est comme la météo,
c’est d’une banalité.
On en parle entre voisins,
on échange des bons plans
sur les meilleures protections, etc.
Cette histoire vous paraît
complètement folle ?
Exagérée, peut-être ?
Pourtant, il est probable
que si les hommes
avaient vraiment été menstrués,
cette fiction serait notre réalité.
Si les hommes avaient leurs règles,
les règles ne seraient pas invisibilisées
comme elles le sont aujourd’hui.
S’ils avaient leurs règles,
on ne mettrait pas en moyenne sept ans
à diagnostiquer l’endométriose.
Pourquoi ?
Car on entendrait mieux
la douleur des hommes
alors qu’une femme est
avant tout plaintive et douillette.
Si cela concernait les cinquante
bons pourcents de l’humanité,
les menstruations seraient
un sujet de santé publique
et non un sujet intime.
Si les hommes avaient leurs règles,
la précarité menstruelle serait
un sujet politique, au même titre
que la faim dans le monde.
Dans l’aide humanitaire,
les associations qui s’y consacrent
sont certes de plus en plus nombreuses,
mais ça ne fait qu’une petite
dizaine d’années qu’elles existent.
Et vérifiez, dans votre pays, comment
sont taxées les protections hygiéniques.
Elles sont parfois catégorisées de
produits de luxe ou non nécessaires.
Comme si nous pouvions nous en passer.
S’ils avaient leurs règles,
ça ne les empêcherait pas
d’aller à l’école ou au travail.
Les femmes, elles, sont encore,
dans plusieurs endroits du monde,
exclues de leurs maisons,
de leurs établissements scolaires,
de leurs lieux de travail
pendant toute la période des règles
car elles sont considérées comme impures.
Les jeunes filles finissent par tant
manquer l’école qu’elles abandonnent.
On le sait, deux tiers des illettrés
dans le monde sont des femmes.
Ayant moins accès à l’éducation
et au monde du travail,
en partie à cause de leurs règles,
elles se résignent à être sans emploi
et donc dépendantes et/ou pauvres.
Si les hommes avaient leurs règles,
parler des menstruations
serait une évidence.
On ne se féliciterait pas en 2021
de créer des projets
dans les établissements scolaires
pour changer le regard sur les règles.
Ils n’auraient pas à être changés,
ils seraient déjà bienveillants,
encourageants.
S’ils avaient leurs règles,
la publicité prônerait les protections
les plus agréables à porter,
les plus respectueuses du corps
et de l’environnement, les plus efficaces.
Aujourd’hui, rien ne compte
plus que la discrétion.
« Pourvu que ça ne se voit pas. »
Et on a tous intégré ces codes.
Cette boîte, par exemple,
elle est au fond de mon sac
depuis une petite dizaine d’années.
Discrète.
Si les hommes avaient leurs règles,
les règles ne seraient plus un tabou.
Et paradoxalement, tout est tabou
dans le corps des femmes.
On montre des corps de femmes
stéréotypés pour nous vendre un yaourt,
mais une femme dont on voit un peu
trop la bretelle du soutien-gorge
elle est indécente.
On sacralise la maternité,
mais le processus corporel
qui nous le permet nous rendrait impures.
Et je ne vous parle même pas
de l'allaitement en public.
« Mesdames, bon sang,
soyez discrètes, couvrez ce sein. »
Ces paradoxes sont pleins de honte.
Nous devrions toujours être
honteuses de quelque chose.
« Ayez honte de votre corps,
ayez honte d’avoir mal,
ayez honte si vos menstruations se voient,
ayez honte d’en parler,
ayez même honte d’utiliser le bon mot. »
Ah oui, les règles, les menstrues,
on ne les nomme pas, on les évoque.
Alors que si les hommes
avaient leurs règles,
Jean-Pierre Pernaut, présentateur
légendaire du 13H, n’aurait pas assumé
son cancer de la prostate,
mais son endométriose stade 3.
Imaginez.
« C’est la fin de cette édition,
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.
Dès demain, vous retrouverez
Patrick Poivre d’Arvor
puisque je me fais opérer
de mon endométriose.
Ne vous en faites pas,
on se retrouve vendredi
pour fêter ensemble,
comme tous les 21 juin,
la fête des menstrues
avec nos envoyés spéciaux
partout en France. Bel après-midi. »
(Applaudissements)
Blague à part, ça nous fait
une belle jambe de savoir
que si les hommes avaient
leurs règles, ce serait différent,
ce n’est que pour vous montrer
qu’on peut changer les choses.
Bien sûr, les gouvernements pourraient,
voire devraient, baisser les taxes
sur les protections hygiéniques.
Ils pourraient considérer les règles
comme un sujet de santé publique,
d'éducation, de médiatisation.
Les publicitaires pourraient faire
un effort dans l’image qu’ils renvoient
et d’ailleurs,
c’est ce qu’ils commencent à faire
parce que nous,
en tant qu’opinion publique,
en tant que société, nous avons du poids.
Nous pouvons décider que
les règles sont un sujet public
et faire pression sur les politiciens
pour faire évoluer les mentalités.
Vous pouvez soutenir
des associations de distribution -
oui, ça existe, d’éducation
et de sensibilisation.
Aidez-les en donnant des serviettes
en offrant du temps,
en faisant des dons d’argent.
Aidez-les en médiatisant leurs actions,
en les soutenant sur
les réseaux sociaux, par exemple.
Si vous êtes professionnellement
en contact avec des jeunes,
vous pouvez décider
que vous parlerez des règles,
que ça en vaut la peine,
que ce n’est plus tabou.
Nous sommes déjà acteurs
et actrices du changement.
Cela ne se fera pas en un jour,
mais collectivement,
nous pouvons changer de regard
et changer de discours sur les règles.
En parler.
Lever le tabou.
Dégager la honte.
Dès ce soir, vous pourrez parler
des règles dans la voiture en rentrant.
Lundi au travail, discutez menstrues
autour de la machine à café
avec les collègues
ou avec Lisa de la compta
dans l’ascenseur.
Bref, vous avez compris l'idée.
À partir de cette conférence,
d’une actualité ou même d’une publicité,
parlons des règles, tout simplement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)